This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个来自I-Heart的播客。由真人录制。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的生活经历，进行在其他任何地方都感到不够安全的坦诚对话，而你是在和一位懂行的执照专业人士进行交流。有多少男人带着盔甲生活。这向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你非得使用它，听听如何去学习吧。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
用艰难的方式在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的天哪，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last
这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪现代世界中关乎心理韧性、健身以及建立恢复力的科学。经历一些艰难险阻，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即数字2和百分号，在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个
target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he does. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. Happy New Year. Welcome to 2020. Welcome to a new year of the podcast. Thank you for joining me. Thanks for being here. I'm currently coming to you from perhaps the most beautiful place in the world. I'm in Japan, in Osaka,
目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。他会得到他应得的惩罚。我们常说，相信你的女朋友们。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《相信女朋友，相信我，宝贝》（Trust the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The psychology of your 20s），这是一个带大家探讨我们在二十岁时经历的一些重大生活转变以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到这个播客。新年快乐。欢迎来到2020——哦不，欢迎来到播客的新一年。感谢大家的加入。感谢你们来到这里。我目前正从可能是世界上最美丽的地方向大家广播。我在日本的大阪，
ringing in the New Year with my family, my friends, my partner. Honestly, it felt like such a well-deserved little break after how crazy last year was for me. We've been eating ramen and fried chicken every day, sleeping in, drinking a lot of beer, playing cards. I just feel so blessed. And I know that sounds so cheesy, but I think this time for me has been really appreciating how much I have to be grateful for moving into the new year. There were some. significant life changes over the past 12 months. And of course, I was just reflecting back on where I was at this time at the beginning of 2023, looking back specifically at my old journal entries from that time. And a lot of what I remember is this distinct fear and anxiety. I had
和我的家人、朋友、伴侣一起迎接新年。老实说，在经历了过去一年对我而言如此疯狂的经历之后，这感觉就像是一个实至名归的小假期。我们每天都在吃拉面和炸鸡，睡懒觉，喝很多啤酒，打牌。我感到非常幸福。我知道这听起来很矫情，但我认为对我来说，这段时间让我真正体会到了在新的一年里我有多少值得感恩的事情。在过去的12个月里，有一些重大的生活改变。当然，我只是回想了一下自己在2023年年初这个时候身在何处，特别回顾了我当时旧的日记。我所记得的很大一部分是这种明显的恐惧和焦虑。我
absolutely no idea what would happen. I was still working my corporate job. I was struggling after my first year living in Sydney was just like very heartbroken and I'll be honest feeling really aimless and lost. Nothing really seemed to have direction or purpose and I just really couldn't have imagined that this much would have changed that my entire life would be completely different a year later coming into 2024. The new year is obviously such a pivotal time for so many of us to reflect on the past to have that moment of introspection for how far we've come. But also perhaps how much further we would like to go. It feels so significant because it is this tangible new beginning for us,
完全不知道会发生什么。我当时还在公司上班。在悉尼生活的第一年后，我一直在挣扎，感到非常心碎，说实话，我感到非常漫无目的和迷失自我。一切似乎都没有方向和目标，我真的无法想象会有这么大的改变，在进入2024年的一年后，我的整个生活会变得完全不同。对于我们很多人来说，新年显然是一个回顾过去、对我们已经走过的路进行内省的关键时刻。但也许也包括我们希望走得更远。这感觉意义重大，因为它对我们来说是一个切实的新开始，
even though, you know, time, years, days, there's such an arbitrary concept. I feel like just the psychological kind of narrative around a new year leaves us with a lot of expectations, a lot of big ambitions. And it's really interesting because I think this concept of a fresh start that a new year brings has been acknowledged by cultures and society. for thousands of years, the Babylonians actually used to celebrate the new year and make New Year's resolutions or like pledges to the gods and like promises that they would fulfill in order to ensure their crops were successful, that their children were healthy to prevent famine.
尽管你知道，时间、年份、日子，这些都只是随意的概念。我觉得关于新年的那种心理叙事给我们留下了很多期望，很多宏大的抱负。这真的很有趣，因为我认为新年带来的这种全新开始的概念已经被各种文化和社会所认可。几千年来，巴比伦人实际上曾经庆祝新年，并许下新年愿望或向神明发誓，并许下他们会履行的承诺，以确保他们的庄稼丰收，他们的孩子健康，以防止饥荒。
And this has been seen in just like so many cultures, this like reverence around the beginning of a new chapter in like ancient Rome. They used to celebrate the god of new beginnings and transitions around this time. There's this really like rich history here that points to the kind of the universal significance that a new year brings. And this is what we're going to discuss today, because this is the time of year four reflecting deeply on what we want for our lives. When we enter into a new year, we need to set our intentions, maybe in the form of New Year's resolutions, but I actually think more powerful is setting our motives, redefining what we see as our purpose. What can we do in this new year so that this time, when we're next year, when we're entering 2025, we can kind of sit back
这在许许多多的文化中都可以看到，这种对新篇章开端的敬畏就像在古罗马一样。他们过去常常在这个时候庆祝新起点和转折之神。这里有着非常丰富的历史，指向了新年带来的普遍意义。这也是我们今天要讨论的内容，因为这是每年深入反思我们对生活期许的时刻。当我们进入新的一年时，我们需要设定我们的意图，也许是以新年愿望的形式，但我实际上认为更有力量的是设定我们的动机，重新定义我们认为的目标。在这个新年中，我们可以做些什么，以便在这个时候，明年，当我们进入2025年时，我们可以坐下来
and say, I made those changes. I invested in the right people. I invested in myself, in the right path, the right decisions. I took the risks that I needed to take. For me, each year, seems to have a theme. Last year, the theme was very much discovery. And this year is the year for taking risks. It is our year for kind of embracing fear, for embracing the unknown, not being afraid of the future, recognizing that we are in control. We are going to take accountability for creating our dream life.
说，我做出了那些改变。我投资了对的人。我投资了自己，选择了正确的道路，做出了正确的决定。我冒了我需要冒的风险。对我来说，每年似乎都有一个主题。去年，主题很大程度上是探索。而今年是冒险之年。这是我们拥抱恐惧、拥抱未知的一年，不畏惧未来，认识到我们掌握着主动权。我们将为创造我们梦想的生活承担责任。
I think risk plays such an important role in this. realization because as we get older, it becomes so much easier to just do what is convenient and easy, just take the path laid out in front of us. We become a lot less active in our own decision making. And I think to be honest, we just get used to being comfortable and not needing much else. But true growth and true happiness comes when we really push beyond what is comfortable, beyond what feels safe to a place of expansion. Also, I say this a lot, but what is easy isn't always what is best. It's not necessarily going to get us to a fulfilled place, I believe so firmly, in challenging
我认为风险在这个实现过程中扮演着如此重要的角色，因为随着我们年龄的增长，做那些方便和轻松的事情，只走摆在我们面前的现成道路，变得越来越容易。我们在自己的决策中变得不那么积极了。说实话，我认为我们只是习惯了安逸，不需要太多其他东西。但真正的成长和真正的幸福来自于我们真正突破舒适区，突破感到安全的界限，走向拓展的境界。另外，我经常这么说，容易走的路并不总是最好的路。它不一定能把我们带到一个充实的地方，我坚信，去挑战
what you expect your life to be, the kind of blueprint that society imposes on us, and just betting on yourself for a little bit, just taking a chance on your dreams, your grand ideas. And that's really, I think, what the focus of 2024 is going to be for me, and I hope it's the focus for you as well. I want to give you an example of how risk has really kind of changed my life. For the longest time, I was convinced that in order to be happy, I really needed to pursue a very secure career. And I needed to push myself to move up the corporate ladder, that the financial security that that would bring would be fundamental to my peace of mind and my future. And last year after months, months of anxiety and worry, I think I realized that my notions and
你对生活的期望，社会强加给我们的某种蓝图，然后稍微押注一下自己，去为你的梦想、你的宏大想法抓住一次机会。我认为这确实将是2024年对我的重点，我也希望这能成为你的重点。我想给你举个例子，说明风险是如何真正改变我的生活的。很长一段时间里，我确信为了幸福，我真的需要追求一份非常稳定的职业。我需要鞭策自己顺着公司晋升阶梯往上爬，这能带来的财务安全感将是我心灵平和和未来的基础。而去年，在经历了几个月的焦虑和担忧之后，我意识到我的观念以及
ideas about what would make me happy were incorrect because I was doing all the things that I thought was going to lead to satisfaction and fulfillment and the sense of security. And I was miserable. I was really miserable. and so I took the risk to quit my job, to do what really truly made me feel fulfilled and kind of aligned with my reason for being on this planet. It wasn't without stress. In fact, it was probably more stressful than when I'd been at my corporate job, especially when it came to financial stability and being able to pay my rent and my bills. But I think I knew that if I didn't
关于什么能让我快乐的想法是不正确的，因为我在做所有我认为会带来满足感、成就感和安全感的事情。而我却很痛苦。我真的很痛苦。因此我冒着风险辞掉了工作，去做那些真正让我感到充实、符合我在这颗星球上生存意义的事情。这并非没有压力。事实上，它可能比我在公司上班时压力更大，尤其是在财务稳定以及能够支付房租和账单方面。但我认为我知道，如果我不
do this, if I didn't take the leap, each year, each month that passed, it would just become harder for me to make that decision and I would regret it. I would be somewhat haunted by the what if of the decisions that I didn't make. So I think there's this conundrum that we all face. When we think about creating our dream life, when we think about the things that we really want to do, there is this inherent choice, this inherent kind of equation that we need to weigh up. Do I stay where I am and remain safe and sure of my surroundings, but possibly regret my decisions later in life or kind of mourn the life I could have lived. Or do I choose to be brave? Do I choose to see what happens? Maybe I'm rewarded for my risk, but if I fail, at least I end up back in the same place I was before with the
这样做，如果我不迈出这一步，随着每一个月、每一年的流逝，我做这个决定就会变得更加困难，而且我会后悔的。我会被那些我没有做出的决定的“如果”所困扰。所以我觉得我们都面临着这样一个难题。当我们考虑创造梦想的生活，当我们考虑真正想做的事情时，有一种内在的选择，一种我们需要权衡的内在公式。我是留在原地，保持安全并确信周围环境，但可能在晚年为自己的决定感到后悔，或者为自己本可以过上的生活感到哀叹？还是我选择勇敢？我选择看看会发生什么？也许我会因为冒险而得到回报，但如果我失败了，至少我回到了以前的地方，并且
knowledge that I tried. That is a really common, I think, mental conundrum that we go through, is we have these two paths and risk obviously requires giving up something. Risk requires maybe giving up a previous dream that you've outgrown, giving up those parts of your life that you are comfortable with, giving up financial stability, giving up friends, giving up relationships. But there are so many benefits and so many rewards that come from that. And I think that there are so many areas in life that we can choose to take risks. We can go back to school. We can take a year off to go solo traveling. We can move to a new city, start a new business, a side hustle, a hobby, whatever it may be. And we can also choose to take a risk around being more honest with people about how we feel, asking people out,
带着我曾尝试过的认知。我认为这是一个非常普遍的心智难题，我们都会经历这两条路径，而风险显然需要放弃某些东西。风险可能需要放弃你已经超越的以前的梦想，放弃生活中让你感到舒适的部分，放弃财务稳定，放弃朋友，放弃恋爱关系。但其中也有这么多的好处和回报。我认为生活中有很多领域我们可以选择冒险。我们可以重返校园。我们可以休假一年去独自旅行。我们可以搬到一个新城市，开始一项新业务、一个副业、一个爱好，无论它是什么。我们还可以选择在对人们更诚实地表达自己的感受、约人出去、
dating more, introducing yourself to strangers, going to things alone, initiating difficult conversations. Obviously, this is not a full list of the risks that I consider important, but These are the risks that especially in our 20s, I think we kind of have a duty to take. You are never going to be this free or this inhibited again. Mistakes are also an inbuilt part of this decade. They are in many ways expected from us. So people give you a lot more what I would call a pass if you are to make the wrong decision. At least you gave it a go.
多约会、向陌生人自我介绍、独自参加活动、开启艰难的对话方面承担风险。显然，这不是我认为重要的风险的完整列表，但这些是风险，特别是当我们二十多岁时，我认为我们有一种责任去承担。你再也不会像现在这样自由或无拘无束了。错误也是这个十年的一个内置部分。在许多方面，人们对我们有这种期待。所以，如果你做出了错误的决定，大家会给你更多我所谓的宽容。至少你尝试过了。
A lot of people cannot say that. A lot of people live with the. mistake of not taking a chance on themselves for their entire lives. I want to talk about one of my favorite studies of all time here. There was this study that examined the power and kind of the psychology of regret and the impact of the decisions that people didn't make on their psyche in the future. What they found is that you are more likely to regret a decision that you didn't make versus one that you did across thousands of people. There were so many of them that expressed more regret for the risks that they didn't take compared to the ones that they did. Actually, 24%
很多人无法这样说。很多人一生都活在没有为自己搏一把的错误中。我想在这里谈谈我历来最喜欢的几项研究之一。有一项研究探讨了遗憾的力量及其心理学，以及人们未做出的决定对他们未来心理的影响。他们发现，成千上万的人表明，相比于做出的决定，你更有可能为自己没有做出的决定感到后悔。有那么多的人对他们没有冒的险表达了更多的遗憾，相比于他们冒过的险。实际上，24%
of participants regretted the things that they did do and 76 regretted the things that they didn't do. So I think this study is important when we consider how we're going to approach risk taking in the new year because it highlights the dangers. of inaction. And not even just inaction, but a denial of your dreams, a denial of that urge of what you know deeply is going to make you happy. It is really such a tragedy to imagine yourself on your deathbed, realizing that there is nothing you can do to undo the past, but wishing that you have been brave when it counted. And I think being brave when it counted is something that we don't always understand or recognize until it's in hindsight. We often don't realize the opportunities
的参与者对自己做过的事情感到后悔，而76%的人对没有做过的事情感到后悔。因此，当我们考虑在新的一年里如何对待冒险时，这项研究很重要，因为它凸显了不作为的危险。甚至不仅仅是不作为，而是对你梦想的否定，对你内心深处明知能让你快乐的冲动的否定。想象自己临终时，意识到自己无法逆转过去，却唯独希望能在大显身手时勇敢一次，这真是一场悲剧。我认为在关键时刻勇敢是我们并不总是能理解或意识到的，直到事后诸葛亮才明白。我们常常意识不到那些机会，
that we have because they are so scary to us until it's too late and I really want to encourage you to be open to what might be coming to you in this new year that you might discredit because it is too scary that you might immediately say no to. Regardless of this understanding of the benefit of risk, even if we appreciate that this could be our future, sometimes we experience a lot of cognitive dissonance around the many choices that we need to make in our 20s. So cognitive dissonance in psychology refers to this kind of mental discomfort experienced when we hold two contradictory beliefs or ideas or values. I think that really applies to the dreams that we have. So we might see ourselves in one way as someone who was really motivated by corporate
因为它们对我们来说太可怕了，直到为时已晚，我真的想鼓励大家对新一年可能到来、但你可能会因为太过害怕而轻视甚至立即拒绝的事情保持开放态度。尽管理解了风险的好处，即便我们认识到这可能是我们的未来，有时我们在二十岁时面对诸多选择时，仍会经历大量的认知失调。因此，心理学上的认知失调是指当我们持有两个相互矛盾的信念、想法或价值观时所经历的一种精神不适。我认为这确实适用于我们拥有的梦想。所以我们可能会以某种方式看待自己，认为自己是一个真正受公司成就驱动的人。
success. We really want to raise a family. We really want to perhaps pursue a quite traditional life. That is one belief that you have about yourself. But another belief is that you want to be a bit of a vagabound, that you are someone who is really independent, really free-spirited, you want to start your own business, you want to travel. And you kind of have these two choices, right? And it feels like in this moment, you have to make a decision. You have to make a decision right. You have to make a decision right now and making a decision requires you to give up on one of those paths. But you have to think about the timing of your dreams in this moment. I have this saying that you can be everything that you want to be, but you can't be at all at once. When we think about the things that we want from our lives,
我们真的很想组建家庭。我们真的可能想追求一种相当传统的生活。这是你关于自己的一种信念。但另一个信念是，你想成为某种意义上的流浪汉，你是一个真正独立、崇尚自由精神的人，你想创业，你想旅行。而你面临这两种选择，对吧？感觉在这个时刻，你必须做出决定。你必须做出正确的决定。你现在就必须做出决定，而做一个决定需要你放弃其中一条路径。但你必须考虑此时梦想的时机。我有这样一句名言：你可以成为你想成为的一切，但你不能同时成为所有。当我们思考对生活的诉求时，
we have to consider what can be postponed, what actually may be better to hold off on, whereas what is best for you right now? When would it be, it be, the best time to do these things. I think when it comes to a lot of those adventurous dreams that particularly people in our 20s really harbor, the time to do those things is right now. It is literally right now. Most of us do not have children. We do not have mortgages. We have exited our like education pipeline. We've either graduated high school or university. And it's in those moments of fear and kind of like the question of what am I going to do with my life from here on out, that we need to be adventuring and discovering and willing to branch out. It's not to say that you can never do these things
我们必须考虑什么可以延后，什么其实更适合暂缓，而当下对你最好的又是什么？什么时候才是做这些事情的最佳时机。我认为，说到年轻人特别是我们二十多岁的人心怀的那些充满冒险精神的梦想，做这些事情的时机就是现在。就是现在。我们大多数人没有孩子。我们没有房贷。我们已经退出了教育流水线。我们要么高中毕业了，要么大学毕业了。正是在那些充满恐惧、面对“从今以后我要如何生活”的疑问的时刻，我们需要去冒险、去探索、去愿意开辟新径。这并不是说一旦过了某个年龄就绝对不能做这些事情，
once you're past to a certain age, but simply that you have to be able to make hard calls about what you want now that may mean that you're going to delay some of the other things in your life till later. Still in those moments, I do think fear is our biggest enemy. The saying always goes, fear is the killer of dreams. I don't think that has ever been more true than when it comes to dreams that require risk, because the essential premise of risk is that the outcome is unknown. And it is a fact that the outcome is unknown that makes it so scary, but also that makes it so exciting. Exciting because, yeah, it could go terribly, but also it could go incredibly well. You have no expectations. You have no idea of what's going to come next. And that just
而只是说你必须对现在想要的东西做出艰难的抉择，这可能意味着你要把生活中的其他一些事情推迟到以后。尽管如此，在那些时刻，我认为恐惧是我们最大的敌人。那句老话说得好，恐惧是梦想的杀手。我认为，当涉及到需要承担风险的梦想时，这句话从未如此真实过，因为风险的基本前提是结果未知。正是结果未知这一事实，让它变得如此可怕，却又如此令人兴奋。令人兴奋是因为，是的，它可能会糟糕透顶，但它也可能会进行得极其顺利。你没有任何期望。你不知道接下来会发生什么。这留下了
leaves so much room for surprises and room for excitement and room for the unexpected. What I really want to discuss, though, is some of the things that kind of hold us back, some of the fears that keep us in a place of comfort, keep us in a place of stability, and how we're going to push back against that anxiety or perhaps that passivity this year. How we're going to embrace risk in all its forms from small to big in 2024. So all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
如此之多的惊喜空间、兴奋空间和充满未知的空间。不过，我真正想讨论的是一些阻碍我们前进的事物、一些让我们留在舒适区和稳定区的恐惧，以及今年我们将如何反击那种焦虑或某种被动性。我们在2024年将如何以从大到小的各种形式拥抱风险。这一切以及更多内容，将在短暂的休息后揭晓。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人所占比率。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪现代世界中关乎心理韧性、健身以及建立恢复力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上具有炎症性。我们搞错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难险阻，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即数字2和百分号，在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小金（Lil' Kim）胸部的那次吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。在这一集中，我们挑出它，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段日期的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Marc Lamont Hill）的访谈，畅谈80年代的可卡因。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
坦白说，84对我来说意义重大，不只是因为可卡因。我愿意在某天谈论可卡因，但为了让你们知道。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集，所以我开始看出一条贯穿线了。我们现在也把艾滋病摆上台面了，所以。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan, Paul. part. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hard Way），我是主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是：特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安、保罗。一部分。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free IHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself
以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却依然在追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的博弈。史蒂夫·布恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得作为地球上的一员做个好人很重要，还是你做个好人只是因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹只是作为一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《艰难抉择》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《艰难抉择》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己
at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
处于父权丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了长达数年的法庭诉讼，以证明真相。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露出一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的天哪，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Ameriopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I was reading this amazing book a while ago called Big Magic by Elizabeth Gilbert. You might know her. She is the author of that very famous book that came out a few years ago called Eat, Pray, Love, and she also has possibly one of the best TED Talks of all time. It's titled Your Illusive, Creative Genius, which quite frankly I think about at least once a week. I watch it always. But in her book,
女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没结束。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。不久前，我在读一本名为伊丽莎白·吉尔伯特（Elizabeth Gilbert）所著的精彩书籍《大魔法》（Big Magic）。你可能认识她。她是几年前出版的那本非常著名的书《一问、祈祷、爱》（Eat, Pray, Love）的作者，她可能还做过史上最好的TED演讲之一。演讲题目是《你那难以捉摸的创作天赋》（Your Elusive Creative Genius），坦率地说，我至少每周都会想起它一次。我一直都在看。但在她的书中，
Big Magic, what she really focuses on is the mental barriers that hold us back from realizing our best lives, because that's what fear really is. It's all about what's mental. It's all about our thoughts. It's all about how we interpret a situation rather than what it actually is. And I think it's this way of thinking, thinking from a place of fear that keeps us buying into this feeling that we are small or not capable of doing what we've dreamed of. You are afraid of making a mistake. You're afraid that you have no talent. You're afraid that it will take too much time to get to where you want to be. But the thing is that that time is going to pass anyways. Either you did something with it or you didn't. You're afraid of it not working out perfectly.
《大魔法》，她真正关注的是阻碍我们实现最佳生活的心理障碍，因为这正是恐惧的本质。这一切都关乎心理。这全关乎我们的想法。这全关乎我们如何解读一个情况，而不是情况本身。我认为正是这种思维方式——从恐惧的角度思考——让我们一直坚信自己很渺小，或者没有能力做我们梦寐以求的事情。你害怕犯错。你害怕自己没有天赋。你害怕达到你想去的地方需要花太多时间。但问题是，时间无论如何都会过去。要么你用它做点什么，要么没有。你害怕事情不能完美地解决。
That's especially the case for perfectionists, overachievers, people who have been taught to do things the right way. You are afraid of disappointing others or yourself. You're afraid that your dreams are embarrassing just because other people don't understand them. You're afraid that you don't have the right background, the right degree, the right education, that so many people have done it before you, that your dreams aren't special. You're afraid of being too late. And trust me, you are never too late if you are still breathing. You're afraid because something went well in your life once, so nothing can possibly go right again. This is a huge cognitive distortion that a lot of us have as if good things in life are like a,
对于完美主义者、追求卓越者以及那些被教导要以正确方式做事的人来说，情况尤其如此。你害怕让别人或自己失望。你害怕自己的梦想很尴尬，只因为其他人不理解。你害怕自己没有正确的背景、正确的学位、正确的教育，害怕有那么多人走在你前面，害怕你的梦想并不特别。你害怕为时已晚。相信我，只要你还在呼吸，就永远不会太晚。你感到害怕，是因为生活中的某件事曾经进展顺利，所以可能再也没有什么能顺利了。这是我们许多人都有的巨大认知失调，好像生活中的好事就像一个，
exist in a bank account and we've withdrawn too much of the money. And so all of the good things in life, all of our, I guess, our balance of good things has been depleted. Life doesn't work that way. And I think the other thing that we're very afraid of is that you're going to give up things in your current life that you love and you won't be able to get them back. That in itself is a massive barrier for social.
存在于银行账户里，而我们已经支取了太多的钱。因此，生活中的所有好事，我想说，我们好事的余额已经耗尽了。生活并不是这样运作的。而且我认为我们非常害怕的另一件事是，你将放弃当前生活中你所爱的东西，并且你将无法找回它们。这本身就是一个巨大的社会障碍。
many of us, a barrier to pursuing a life that it might actually be better for us. But like we said before, it's going to require sacrifice. Here is the important thing to remember. Fear is not real until it is realized. The easiest way for a fear to never be realized is to never do anything risky that will allow you to grow. You can stay in your safe bubble your entire life and never have to encounter any of those worries being realized. But at the end of your life, you're going to have to face an even bigger fear. The one that you let your life pass you by and you never did anything about it. You never did anything that was going to potentially make you happier. And with that comes a lot of bitterness around what could have been. What if my life had been different at this moment and now
对我们许多人来说，这是追求一种可能对我们更好的生活的障碍。但正如我们之前所说，这需要牺牲。这里有一件重要的事情要记住。恐惧在成为现实之前并不是真实的。让恐惧永不变成现实的最简单方法，就是永远不做任何能让你成长的冒险事情。你可以一辈子待在安全的泡沫里，永远不必面对那些担忧变成现实。但在生命尽头，你将不得不面对更大的恐惧。那就是你任由生活从身边溜走，却从未采取任何行动。你从未做任何可能让你更快乐的事情。随之而来的是对本该如何的种种苦涩。如果我的生活在那个时刻有所不同，而现在
there's nothing I can do about it. I worry about that all the time. It's that perspective of future me that really, I think, keeps me in a place of taking chances on myself. Of course, I think that doesn't mean that you should take every risk that comes across your plate, that you should do anything that you desire or act on every whim. There are obviously some risks that are more calculated, more practical, more meaningful than others, and then there are some that are just plain ridiculous. You're not going to go and jump out of a plane and you've never done it before just because you're ready to embrace risk. Like that is not a smart risk. That is not one that is practical.
我对此无能为力。我一直都在担心这一点。正是这种对未来的“我”的视角，我认为，才真正让我坚持为自己抓住机会。当然，我认为这并不意味着你应该抓住每一个迎面而来的风险，不意味着你应该做你渴望的任何事情或对每一个心血来潮采取行动。显然，有些风险比其他风险更经过深思熟虑、更实用、更有意义，而有些则简直荒谬。你绝不会在以前从未做过的情况下直接从飞机上跳伞，只因为你准备好拥抱风险了。因为那不是明智的风险。那并不实用。
But there are some risks that we call bounded. Bounded risks are amazing. The idea is that there are these types of risks that have limited downsides but unbounded upsides. Essentially what that means is that although there are limited costs incurred, and yes, there will be some costs, time, money, missed opportunities to get this idea off the ground. The benefit is that there is no limit to the benefit. These are the risks that you should be taking. I think about them, especially in terms of this podcast, right?
但有些风险我们称之为有界风险（bounded risks）。有界风险太棒了。其理念是，这类风险具有有限的下行空间和无限的上行空间。本质上，这意味着尽管产生了有限的成本，是的，会有一些成本——时间、金钱、错失让这个想法起步的机会。但好处是，收益是没有上限的。这些才是你应该承担的风险。我特别从这个播客的角度来考虑它们，对吧？
Or like content creation. So when I began this podcast, obviously I had to invest some time into buying a microphone and setting up a platform and creating episodes. but what I've realized now is that there was an unlimited benefit from being able to do something that I loved and engage with people and share and converse with people who really shared my passions. And then there are these risks that are called unbounded. These are not so great. These are the risks that we should avoid.
或者像内容创作。当我开始这个播客时，显然我不得不投入一些时间来购买麦克风、建立平台和制作剧集。但我现在意识到的是，能够做我热爱的事情、与人互动、分享并与真正有共同激情的人交流，这带来了无限的好处。然后还有一种被称为无界风险（unbounded)的风险。这些就没那么好了。这些是我们应该避免的风险。
So actually they're pretty terrible because these risks mean that you could lose everything. So compared to bounded risks in which you can kind of control how much you lose, with unbounded risks, there is no limit to what you will have to give up. And so whilst the payoff might be potentially unlimited, it means that you're probably going to lose something pretty valuable in order to get there. Jumping out of a plane, that's a big one. If you've never skydive before, there is no limit to how much you could potentially lose in this situation, the limit being that you could lose your life.
所以实际上它们相当糟糕，因为这些风险意味着你可能会失去一切。因此，与你可以控制损失程度的有界风险相比，对于无界风险来说，你必须放弃的东西是没有上限的。因此，虽然回报可能是潜在无限的，但这意味着为了达到目标，你可能会失去一些非常宝贵的东西。从飞机上跳伞，这就是一个大风险。如果你从未进行过高空跳伞，在这种情况下你可能会失去的东西是没有上限的，极限就是你可能会失去生命。
And the payoff is actually not really worth it, right? Another one is like choosing to burn all your bridges at your previous workplace or with all your friends because it's going to leave you unmoored and allow you to make more friends. That is not a good risk. That is not a good risk for it's you lose a lot more than you seek to gain. So when we think about risks from this perspective, from kind of a cost-benefit analysis kind of perspective, we really need to consider whether the decisions we're going to make are going to lead to a benefit that's going to outweigh the initial costs.
而回报其实并不真的值得，对吧？另一个例子是选择烧毁你在前一个工作场所或所有朋友的所有桥梁，因为这会让你无依无靠，从而允许你结交更多朋友。这不是一个好风险。这不是一个好风险，因为你失去的远比你试图获得的要多。因此，当我们从这个角度、从成本收益分析的角度来思考风险时，我们确实需要考虑我们将要做出的决定是否会带来超过初始成本的好处。
It's important to be a little bit rational when we think about the risks that we want to take in our 20s. Because although risk equals fear, it does not equal complete abandonment of everything you love and care about. I really do believe, once again, that the most amazing growth will come out of the periods of greatest discomfort where we really push ourselves and explore what's out there, but that doesn't necessarily mean that you have to be silly about it or you have to completely abandon or logic. Taking a risk still requires judgment. And yes, there are people who are more likely to take risks, that that doesn't necessarily mean that you should be doing things that
在思考我们在二十多岁时想要承担的风险时，保持一点理性是很重要的。因为虽然风险等于恐惧，但这并不等于完全抛弃你所热爱和关心的一切。我确实再次相信，最惊人的成长将来自于最不舒服的时期，在那里我们真正突破自我并探索外面的世界，但这并不一定意味着你必须对此表现得愚蠢，或者你必须完全抛弃逻辑。承担风险仍然需要判断力。是的，有些人更容易承担风险，但这并不意味着你应该做那些
you know aren't going to make you happy or aren't actually aligned just because you want to be free, just because you want to be uninhibited, just because you want to see what happens. I think that brings me to another important point. Risks don't have to be inherently spontaneous to be risky. They can also be planned. I think we often think about risks as being these things that are very impulsive that just kind of come to mind and we have to see them through. But you can take your time. You can be prepared. You can talk it through with family and friends. but the most important thing in that moment is to make sure that your preparation is not actually just an unconscious form of avoidance.
你知道不会让你快乐或实际上并不契合的事情，仅仅是因为你想获得自由，仅仅是因为你想无拘无束，仅仅是因为你想看看会发生什么。我认为这让我想到了另一个重要点。风险不一定要生来具有冲动性才叫风险。它们也可以是有计划的。我认为我们经常认为风险是非常冲动的事情，只是浮现在脑海中，我们就必须坚持到底。但你可以花时间。你可以做好准备。你可以与家人和朋友进行讨论。但那个时刻最重要的事情是确保你的准备实际上不是回避的无意识形式。
You are never going to feel fully ready for anything ever. There will always be some doubt. There will always be something that you cannot account for. And often, when we overplan and overthink, that is really just an unconscious way of us choosing to avoid fear, where we get stuck in this like loop of being, of being like if I just know more, if I'm just, if I have a few more days to prepare a few more months, the outcome is going to be better. That is not always the case. Things turn out how they're going to turn out, regardless of how much planning you put into it. So I think there are ways that we can
你永远不会对任何事情感到完全准备就绪。总会有一些疑问。总会有一些你无法解释的因素。通常，当我们过度规划和过度思考时，这实际上只是我们选择逃避恐惧的一种无意识方式，我们陷入了这样一种循环：如果我们了解更多，如果我们准备得更好，如果我们有更多几天或几个月的准备时间，结果就会更好。事实并非总是如此。事情会按照它们注定的方式发展，无论你投入了多少规划。所以我认为有一些方法我们可以
become more familiar or comfortable with the idea of risk. Firstly, think about small risks you can take to prepare yourself for a bigger risk you know is going to come in your future. So, for example, if you want to go traveling or move to a new country for a year, two years, take time to visit that country first just to make sure that it's actually what you like. So you don't get over there and then realize that this was a huge mistake and you want to fly back home immediately. If you want to quit your job, go to a few networking events or start your side hustle whilst you're still working to get a feel for it. Prepare yourself for risk. Don't deny yourself of the risk, but implement it in your daily life or aspects of it in your daily life before you take the full leap.
变得更熟悉或更适应风险的概念。首先，考虑你可以承担的小风险，为你知道未来会发生的更大风险做好准备。例如，如果你想去旅游或搬到一个新国家生活一两年，先花时间去那个国家参观一下，以确保那真的是你喜欢的。这样你就不会到了那里才意识到这是一个巨大的错误，并想立刻飞回国内。如果你想辞职，在工作的同时去参加一些社交活动或开始你的副业来感受一下。为风险做好准备。不要剥夺自己冒险的权利，但在你全力迈出这一步之前，将其落实到你的日常生活或日常生活的某些方面中。
With any risk that involves giving up work, giving up opportunities, giving up education, giving up jobs, take a solid look at your finances before you choose to do that. Like I said before, sometimes you do have to be practical, even if you're going to be risky. I did this at the start of last year and it was really important to understand what the next few months of my life were, or years even, were going to look like so I didn't kind of just step off the deep end and there were suddenly, not just so many unknowns, but so many ways that I could have been prepared mentally, financially, emotionally, and wasn't. I also think instead of thinking about risk as these big decisions we need to make that will
对于任何涉及放弃工作、放弃机会、放弃教育、放弃职位的风险，在你选择这样做之前，好好审视一下你的财务状况。就像我之前说的，有时你确实必须切合实际，即使你要去冒险。我在去年年初就这样做了，了解我生活的接下来的几个月甚至几年会是什么样子真的很重要，这样我就不会直接跳入深渊，突然之间不仅有那么多未知数，而且有那么多我本可以在精神、财务、情感上做好准备却没有做好的地方。我还认为，不要把风险看作我们需要做出的、将要
forever alter our lives, think about them as value realignment. Risks are a way for you to shift your life back in the direction that aligns with how you see yourself, with what you value from life, with what you want from your future. and maybe you've just become really detached from that in the past a year or two. Perhaps you see yourself as a creative, someone who has like a real true fire in their belly for producing work that really moves people from expressing their imagination. But at the moment, you've been really caught up in finishing your business degree that you haven't made time to pursue those parts of you.
彻底改变我们的生活，把它们当作价值观的重新调整。冒险是让你将生活拉回与你的自我认知、与你对生活的价值观、与你对未来的期望相一致的方向的一种方式。也许在过去的一两年里，你与这些已经变得非常疏离。也许你认为自己是一个有创造力的人，内心有着一团真正的火焰，渴望创作出真正能通过表达想象力来打动人们的作品。但目前，你太热衷于完成商业学位，以至于没有时间去追求你那部分的梦想。
Maybe the risk you need to take then is to move out of your comfort zone and pursue this more deeply by carving out time to do it, by setting yourself long-term goals in which you're going to realign how you're living your life with how you wish you were living your life. Maybe you also value being really adventurous and a bit of a nomad, but you perhaps felt a little bit stuck post-COVID, you feel the need to work full-time to make money for your dreams. The risk you need to take is to just get back out there. Normally, when we are like, you know, like, you're I said, over planning, over preparing. What we're really fearing in those moments is not being unprepared, it's being uncomfortable. So you kind of have to get comfortable with being uncomfortable
也许你需要冒的险就是走出舒适区，通过腾出时间来更深入地追求这一点，通过为你的人生设定长期目标，让你的生活方式与你所向往的生活方式重新契合。也许你也喜欢冒险、渴望像个游牧民一样生活，但在疫情过后，你可能感到有些困惑，觉得需要全职工作来为梦想赚钱。你需要冒的险就是重新走出去。通常，当我们像我说的那样，过度规划、过度准备时，我们在那些时刻真正害怕的不是毫无准备，而是感到不适。所以你必须学会习惯不适感，
and kind of say, you know, fuck it. This is actually what I want from my life, even if it's difficult at times, even if people don't understand it. I'm at this point where I can either choose to deny myself that dream or that vision for my life or I can choose to embrace it. Risks are really Not just a catalyst for change, but a catalyst for realigning your true self with your actual self. Taking yourself off the path that everyone else wants you to live and back onto the path that you want to live. So I want to talk about some of the risks that I'm going to take this year to finish it off. I really want to solo travel. I used to be completely terrified of planes.
然后有点像说，去他的吧。这实际上是我对生活的期望，即使有时很困难，即使别人不理解。我正处于这样一个阶段：要么我选择否定我那个梦想或对生活的愿景，要么我选择拥抱它。冒险真的不仅仅是改变的催化剂，更是将你的真实自我与现实自我重新对齐的催化剂。把你从别人希望你过的生活道路上拉回来，带回到你想过的生活道路上。所以我想聊聊今年为了收尾我打算冒的一些险。我真的很想独自旅行。我过去对飞机完全感到恐惧。
And it meant that when everyone else around me was taking those times to do their Europe trips or their Southeast Asia trips, I was kind of stuck at home because I was too scared to embark on this journey, mainly just like the first 14 hours of the journey on the plane. So I think that I regret not having those experiences that a lot of my friends have been able to have. So I really want to solo travel this year. I really want to get into a position where I can live alone. and force myself to make that decision when the time comes rather than just reverting to living with friends or living with a partner. I think that I really want that space to know myself, even though I'm scared of being lonely. And I really want to set myself a really big athletic goal. That might not sound like a risk for a lot of people, but I think my fear has always been of
这意味着当周围每个人都在花时间进行欧洲旅行或东南亚旅行时，我只能呆在家里，因为我太害怕踏上这段旅程了，主要也就是害怕飞机上的前14个小时。所以我觉得我很遗憾没有经历过很多朋友都能够拥有的那些经历。因此我今年真的很想独自旅行。我真的很想让自己能够一个人生活，并且在时机成熟时强迫自己做出这个决定，而不是仅仅退而求其次地和朋友或伴侣住在一起。我想我真的很需要那个空间来了解自己，尽管我害怕孤独。而且我真的很想给自己设定一个非常宏大的运动目标。这听起来对很多人来说可能不算冒险，但我认为我的恐惧一直来自于
failing or embarrassing myself of not meeting people's expectations for what someone who participates in these activities looks like, not being fit enough to do it or to fit in. And that's really kept me and held me back from participating in activities that I think I otherwise would have really loved and would have made a lot of friends from. That's what I want to do this year. I want to challenge myself to not be constantly worrying about what other people think about me and my behaviors and my actions and just do it anyways. One final reminder before we wrap up this episode.
失败或让自己感到尴尬，害怕达不到别人对参与这些活动的人的外表期望，害怕自己不够强壮而无法胜任或融入其中。这确实让我退缩，阻碍我参与那些我认为自己本会非常喜欢并且能结交很多朋友的活动。这就是我今年想做的事。我想挑战自己，不再总是担心别人对我和我的行为、举动有什么看法，不管怎样，先做再说。在结束这一集之前，还有最后一个提醒。
You have a responsibility to yourself to actually just do things, to make decisions that might leave you feeling temporarily a little bit out of place, but will significantly change your life, will set you on a new course. No one is going to come and suddenly make your life amazing for you. you are the only one that can do that. And maybe not everyone will understand your motivations. Maybe you don't even know what risk would look like for you in this year. It doesn't matter though, because in this life, you can choose to be comfortable or you can
你对自己的生活负有责任，那就是去行动，去做出可能会让你暂时感到有些格格不入，但会显著改变你的生活、让你踏上新征程的决定。没有人会突然出现并让你的生活变得无比美好，只有你自己才能做到这一点。也许并非每个人都能理解你的动机。也许你甚至不知道今年对你来说冒险意味着什么。但这并不重要，因为在这个世界上，你可以选择安于舒适，或者你可以
choose to grow. I know I've said it so many times throughout this, but I do think that we need the reminder that when we buy into fear, we also buy into dissatisfaction and we buy into regret. And that's not something that I think we want to live with. and if you're not quite sure what it means to you to take a risk, what you would take a risk towards, leave yourself open to opportunity. And when I say leave yourself open to opportunity, what that really means is that be prepared to say yes to things in the moment. Be prepared to just be open to the idea that your expectations for what you wanted your life to look like might
选择成长。我知道我在整段节目中已经说过很多次了，但我确实认为我们需要被提醒：当我们向恐惧妥协时，我们也向不满妥协，向遗憾妥协。这不是我们想要的生活方式。如果你还不太清楚冒险对你意味着什么，你愿意为什么去冒险，那就让自己对机遇保持开放。当我指对机遇保持开放时，它真正的意思是：准备好在当下对事物说“好”。准备好接受这种想法：你对未来生活的期望可能会
change and might not be the same. And also put yourself in situations where you can be challenged, go and try new things, interact with new types of people, look for new jobs that you might be interested in, even if you're not even going to apply for them. You know, watch travel vlogs of people doing really cool things. Think about the things that you loved maybe in childhood, the dreams you had in childhood that you've kind of neglected, that you've forgotten about. It's a really good way to, I think, really tune into what you want from your life that you've maybe neglected. So I want to say, officially, welcome to your year for taking risks in whatever capacity you choose to do that. Welcome.
改变，可能不再是原来的样子。同时，把自己放在能接受挑战的环境中，去尝试新鲜事物，与不同类型的人交流，寻找你可能感兴趣的新工作，哪怕你根本不打算去申请。去看那些展示人们做酷事的旅游vlog吧。想想你童年时可能喜欢的事物，那些你在童年时怀揣过却被你忽视、被你遗忘的梦想。我认为，这是真正契合你内心对生活渴望的一个非常好的方法，而这些渴望或许曾被你忽视。所以我想正式宣布：欢迎来到你勇于冒险的一年，无论你选择以何种方式去实现它。欢迎。
I'm so excited to hear from you about what are the risks you are going to take in 2024. What are the things that you are going to realize or at least just explore this year? are you going to push past your fear and your anxiety to maybe discover something about yourself that you never knew? I'm really excited to see what that means, not just for me, but for all of you, my lovely listeners. I'm so excited for this year. It's just crazy how fast time is going. I'm not going to think about it too much. I feel like that will lead me into such an existential spiral. But I also just want to say thank you so much for your support in 2023. My, my entire life truly did change and that would not have been possible without you, every single one of
我非常期待听到你们分享在2024年准备去冒什么样的险。今年你们打算实现或至少去探索哪些事情？你们是否会突破恐惧和焦虑去发现一些从未了解过的自己？我真的很期待看到这对不仅是我，还有对你们所有人——我可爱的听众们——意味着什么。我对今年充满期待。时间过得真是快得惊人。我不想去过多思考这一点，感觉那会让我陷入无尽的虚无主义。但我也只想对大家在2023年的支持表示由衷的感谢。我的人生确实彻底改变了，如果没有你们，这一切都是不可能实现的，每一位
you who listens every single week, who supports me in silent ways, who shares episodes with friends, it's just, it's just mind-blowing that I have this community and every day I'm just so grateful for it. I'm so grateful for it. I really don't have the words, so I guess I'll just say one more time. Thank you so much. and hopefully I will see more of you this year. I will see more of you in 2024. If you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now,
每周都来收听、以无声的方式支持我、与朋友分享节目的你们，拥有这样一个社群简直让我感到不可思议，我每天都对此充满感激。我真的感激不尽。我实在无法用言语表达，所以我想最后再多说一次：非常感谢你们。希望今年能见到更多的你们。我会在2024年与你们相见更多。如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你目前正在收听的任何平台上留下五星好评，
share it with a friend if this is what they need to hear. Make sure you're following for all of our new episodes this year. And we will be back next week with another episode. Happy New Year. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really
如果这也是你的朋友需要听的话，请分享给他们。确保关注我们今年的所有新节目。我们下周将带着另一集回归。新年快乐。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Games带来的《Learn the Hardway》。这个节目主要探讨黑人男性的生活经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他地方是
not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was a accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct?
真的不安全去进行的，但你现在正与一位知晓如何应对的持证专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人一直穿着一副盔甲？这向世界传递出一种信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你曾两次伪造这份特定的检测报告，对吧？
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
我伪造了一次检测报告。这需要动用一大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格，一名女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《被困的爱》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的推进，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将会以一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的姿态从另一端走出来。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
请在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》，也就是TWO%。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的诈骗犯约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。收听《女朋友们》。
Trust me, babe, on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
相信我，宝贝，请在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个IHeart播客，确保为真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。